bonsoir fidor rid of merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france une action
en responsabilité qu'est ce que cela
veut dire exactement
écoutez il ya des responsables de la
catastrophe sociale qui est en train de
se produire chez général elektriks à
villeurbanne mais pas seulement à
villeurbanne sur beaucoup d'autres sites
celui de belfort aussi bien sûr et les
responsables il faut les faces
sanctionné parce que c'est très simple
ce qui s'est produit
général elektriks à l'origine toutes ses
usines étaient des usines alstom les
salariés travailler pour alstom et
général electrics est venu racheter
c'est si vite c'est infrastructures
industrielles et évidemment concept
toucher des intérêts stratégiques de la
france puisque ses usines fabriquent des
outil extrêmement important pour y
compris la défense il a fallu que
général elektriks s'engage au moment du
rachat à maintenir ses activités en
france et aussi à maintenir les salariés
dans leurs emplois
et puis ils sont même allés plus loin au
moment de la vente
général elektriks a dit franchement
n'ayez aucune inquiétude
nous allons nous engager à créer 1000
emplois en plus de ce qui existe au
moment où nous devenons propriétaire de
ses usines donc évidemment tout le monde
à ce moment là à considérer parce que
s'était couché sur papier il ya un
contrat qui a été con que ses
engagements à l'être tenu que général
elektriks allait effectivement augmenté
le nombre de salariés à l'intérieur de
ses usines en france
floquet ce qui tient de centre a donc
feeder enough
comment quels sont les arguments avancés
par par l'entreprise justement pour
justifier cette rupture de contrat et le
non respect de sa promesse avant de
parler de ça il faut surtout souligner
que non seulement ils n'ont pas
construit d'emplois supplémentaires ils
n'ont pas augmenté le nombre de postes
dans l'usiné mais ils ont fait
exactement le contraire de ce qu'ils
avaient promis ils ont supprimé des
emplois
ça fait des années qu'ils détruisent par
centaines des postes à l'intérieur de
ces usines et ils font ça sans que
quiconque ne réagisse et je dirais que
dans dans lucky conquis a surtout l'état
qui d'une passivité absolument
incroyable et inacceptable parce que
lorsque général elektriks a pris cet
engagement de créer des emplois un très
précisément mille emplois l'état a dit
aux salariés
je serai le garant du respect de cette
promesse par général
x je suis ici en quelque sorte le vigile
en charge de faire respecter cette
promesse par général elektriks et
lorsque le groupe étasunien a commencé à
détruire des emplois donc encore une
fois à faire le contraire de ce à quoi
il s'était engagé l'état non seulement
n'est pas intervenue mais a participé
d'une certaine manière a posé un voile
sur ces événements et a accompagné du
général elektriks dans la violation de
ses engagements
et comme le disait le salarié tout à
l'heure l'action que nous avons engagées
elle a pour but c'est tout simple de
faire condamner celui qui a manqué à sa
promesse celui qui a violé ses
engagements à savoir général elektriks
mais nous voulons aussi mettre en
lumière mettre en évidence l'attitude de
l'état qui est scandaleuse et qui a fait
lui aussi le contraire de ce qu'il avait
promis
non seulement il n'atteint garantit le
respect de ses engagements il n'est pas
intervenu pour contraindre alstom a
respecté sa promesse mais a aidé en
réalité alstom pardon de général
elektriks à a violé ses engagements a
violé sa promesse
ma question pardonnez moi si je peux
poser tout de même une question au
milieu comment vous expliquer l'attitude
justement du géant américain des aussi
l'attitude très passive de l'état
écoutez moi j'explique ça de façon
relativement simple je crois que depuis
le début
l'état et l'état
en l'occurrence en 2014 celui qui
étonnait ses propos extrêmement
rassurant c'était ma première voilà
c'est lui qui était aux manettes de
cette opération
je crois que depuis le début ils ne
disent pas la vérité je crois que depuis
le début il savait que de général
elektriks n'allait pas remplir ses
engagements
on a jeté de la poudre aux yeux aux
salariés et pas seulement aux salariés
voilà tous les observateurs en faisant
croire qu'on allait être extrêmement
prudent et vigilant pour faire respecter
ses engagements par le général elektriks
alors qu'en réalité on savait que le
groupe n'avait pas respecté ses
promesses allaient faire le contraire
détruire des emplois et l'attitude de
macron est-ce que franchement elle est
si étonnante que ça est ce que on peut
vraiment être surpris du fait qu' il a
fait dans cette affaire le contraire de
ce à quoi il s'était engagé lui aussi de
son côté
moi non je pense que c'est pas
surprenant parce que vous voyez
idéologiquement macro son gouvernement
tout se voit là qui participe à sa
politique estime que c'est bien qu'une
entreprise et surtout plus grandes
firmes internationales puissent
librement licenciés en france que les
usines et même lorsque elle participe
d'une activité qui relève de l'intérêt
national puisse être démantelé voilà
parce que leur démantèlement permet à
quelques actionnaires de ces grandes
multinationales de faire encore
davantage de profits parce que ces
opérations de suppressions d'emplois de
démolition des usines ne sont pas en
quelque sorte une démarche
voilà esthétique pour voilà cesser ses
actionnaires qu'ils trouveraient ça
commence à amusant de
question pardonnez moi mais de figurines
of que qu'espèrent les plaignants et que
peuvent-ils obtenir selon vous ce sera
ma dernière question qu'est ce qu'ils
peuvent obtenir
eh bien écoutez d'abord ils peuvent
faire éclater la vérité au grand jour ce
qui est quand même pas mal et c'est ça
qu'ils veulent absolument ils veulent
que l'on puisse enfin mettre en évidence
que leur situation est le résultat d'une
violation patente spectaculaire est
inadmissible de promesses qui avaient
été garantis au plus haut niveau de
l'état
ça c'est évidemment leur premier
objectif et puis ils sont aujourd'hui à
deux doigts d'être licencié et donc ils
vont se retrouver au chômage ils vont
subir un préjudice chacun et chacune de
ses salariés va être dans une situation
économique extrêmement compliqué dans
les mois à venir et donc ils vont
évidemment demander réparation à ceux
qui sont les responsables
encore une fois de cette catastrophe qui
s'est produite il ya déjà quelques
années qui est enfin dénoncée et je
crois que voilà il ya beaucoup de
salariés parmi ceux de général elektriks
qui n'ont pas encore rejoint la démarche
qui vont se décider à le faire et voilà
il justice sera rendue
merci beaucoup fils d'or et d'avoir être
avec nous en direct sur rt france merci